pour combien de like on fait un petit
frère Liliana
[Applaudissements]
après je sais que vous allez dire ouais
c'est aussi voilà c'est alors sachez que
c'est leur mode de fonctionnement il
montre leur vie sur les réseaux sociaux
vraiment c'est vraiment le voilà c'est
leur marque de fabrique donc voilà c'est
ils font toujours ça quoi ils veulent
pas aller travailler au lieu de faire
des milliers d'euros c'est un travail
ils prennent les gens pour des milliers
d'euros moments où soumet on fait un
sondage pour faire un enfant
ça va être quoi après à 50000 likes on
débranche mamie enfin c'est n'importe
quoi
à chaque fois que tu veux les insulter
eux c'est pas eux t'insulte ce sont tous
les gens qui like eux et qu'il les
aiment mais pas du tout mais tous les
ados tu as pas 15 ans tous les ados qui
a 15 ans adorent les suivre garde ça
comme un feuilleton toi quand tu avais
15 ans tu